hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today i am watching the
far cry
6 worldwide gameplay reveal that
actually went live this morning
and first up i just want to say i
contemplated waking up at 2 30 a.m
because i'm in australia that would be
the australian time of this gameplay
revealed to watch this
and it started with a 30 minute
countdown timer
if any publisher happens to be watching
this please don't do that
people who work full-time jobs like i do
which i'm sure a lot of us do
or are in the australian time zone um
please start your conferences at the
time that you advertise that they're
starting rather than have people wait
a half hour in any case i'm excited to
watch it so let's just do what people
couldn't do this morning
and skip ahead here we go
so interesting they all say ubisoft
original now what can true yarns do
to serbian true artists
have long memories we remember
our so-called civilized nations treated
us when we needed the most
he's such a good actor
are you concerned about the terrorists
who call themselves
libertad
i just love his face
this is all looking like cinematic so
far you're an orphan
see why do you want to run remember
danny castillo
has kept you an orphan i only see you
certainly looks like fall cry
so why are you here i watched castillo
order a whole vote about people shot to
death
and i want to know who's going to help
me take him down
okay appreciated that
castillo's got what 300 000 troops i
count
six burnt out ears and you put the
bullet to the leg
you can
[Music]
i imagine you can still choose between a
male or female protagonist
is it good in the last one that usually
work
50 50.
i am nothing like him
surely that's not it no okay it was like
what
i was going to say that is not a video
game hi there
it's brookwood director of far cry 6.
and i'm so excited to represent our team
and finally show you our game in action
with far cry 6 we're going to throw you
into our most ambitious
open world yet yara an island deep in
the heart of the caribbean
filled with rich tropical ecosystems
alongside decaying urban landscapes
yara is an island of contrasts isolated
and frozen in time
for over 50 years after a violent
revolution cut it off from the rest of
the world but it's not a political
now finds itself on the verge of
collapse it's a little far cry 3 but
like it has cities in it last year we
introduced you to yara's presidente
anton castillo
with an amazing performance by giancarlo
esposito
a castile must be a lion for yara
he's full of lambs the reception we've
had to anton and diego
has been incredible and we're just
getting started
anton is a man hell-bent on returning
yara
to his idea of its former glory and
while his motivations are far more
complex than they seem
the cost of his vision will be paid in
blood
if a dog refuses that looks
amazing then we must
put them down to achieve his dream for
yara and his son diego
anton has clamped down on freedoms
instituted brutal social reforms
and cast anyone who speaks out against
him into forced labor
his oppression of the yarin people has
pushed the island
to the brink of revolution i love him
that's what popcorn villains do though
they're often very likeable
considered a jewel of the caribbean is
now
a powder keg and you
are the match your name is danny rojas
and you'll experience the revolution
through danny's eyes
right from the beginning born and raised
in yara's capital city
you're a young military dropout who
wants nothing to do with anton
or the revolution you just want to get
the hell out of yara
but once you're face to face with
anton's brutality
you realize that the only chance to live
free
is to lead an army of gorillas into a
new revolution
with the very soul of the island at
stake and i need you here with us man
at the start of your journey you'll get
to pick your identity
and customize your figure while you
navigate the ranks
of the guerrilla movement every aspect
of the game has been developed with the
goal to make you
feel like a guerrilla fighter that's
some drones there's an asymmetric war
against anderson
the gorilla fantasy is all about making
one gorilla
feel like a thousand embracing this was
at the core of how we crafted our
gameplay
our world and the characters you'll meet
along the way
in yara you'll find other gorillas black
market dealers
and everyday yarns who each have their
own reasons for joining the cause
including our friendly gorilla juan
cortez
a master of invention an architect of
revolution
cool he's very the teacher assassin's
creed of them
gotta have your inventor and class
starts now
no horse riding accepts me for some
weird reason
i don't know why
guapo you listen rule 16 aguerriero's
revolution never ends
always another war another cantina
another ugly bartender
this is a [ __ ] waste of time i didn't
see that coming
what i'm gonna make you a wallet my
friend
all your family gonna be wallets
okay but we're just getting started
rule number one a good guerrilla
we lead our operations in secret camps
across the country
here
black market dealers these safe havens
got everything
real needs even do-it-yourself vehicles
i don't remember if they said what
platforms this is on i assume that it
will be on everything
rule number two a good gabria masters
their environment
this land is your home
the scenic shots very pretty
yeah i love the bow shorelines
dead in towns i wonder how dense they
are
i mean we know ubisoft can do it
[Music]
if you want to play it safe take our
secret paths
carved in the dirt of old revolutions
let's go hold up
how are you doing honestly i just don't
think we've had enough games
where we get emotionally attached to a
horse and then it dies
but i'm not going to mention which ones
that happens and we can spoil this
but it's been happening
you don't always need to be a loved one
you do self towers
christmas trees do you even grow those
here mexicans pay crazy money for this
how you think the president maria's new
face
okay
rule number three [ __ ] up situations
call for [ __ ] up solutions
hey he's not here if you expected
reinforcements
i got news for you you're an army of one
against an army of thousands when [ __ ]
gets real
we make use of whatever we
i wonder if it'll get like uh what was
it called batteries
new dawn [ __ ] our new door to equipment
that's some really creative weapons it
was quite fun in terms of the weaponry
specifically
some very unique yeah look at that
the far cry that was all pink on the
cover had a gun very similar to that
[Music]
i don't mind them getting sillier we're
moving further and further away from
malaria i'll make it fun damn
you and i both know you
it's
oh and the final rule i really like the
production of this
who is this young man
very scary who is that you sweet
so there you have it far cry 6 will be
available on october 7th
we hope you enjoyed this first glimpse
of gameplay we have a lot more coming
soon that we can't wait to
really thank you so much for watching
thank you see you next time
okay he was a very good speaker um
not that they haven't been lately we
have a lot of devs doing these
presentations instead of hosts or
whatever and i think i prefer that but
sometimes dev's on great speakers he was
fantastic
um my overall take on hang on we're just
gonna go back to the dog
real quick
yeah they know how to get us they really
do they've been doing the
what was it boomer in the far cry they
know how to get us um my overall
response to this one is
it certainly looks like far cry um
like yeah some of those characters seem
really interesting i actually
enjoy these slightly sillier weapons um
and i feel like it fits the tone in this
case
i have seen yeah commentary on social
media where you know i
tried to avoid any spoilers i could to
wait till after work to watch this
um but yeah they said like the game's
not political but i feel like it's so
clearly political in theme
it's like themes of oppression and war
and
um clearly some kind of dictatorship so
that's what it seems like it's going to
be about some kind of power struggle
with
the presidente uh who again is an actor
that i absolutely love
i like the lead character but overall
i'm not blown away by this this doesn't
even necessarily convince me that i'm
definitely going to
um finish far cry 6 i'm sure i'll try it
um but that's the thing that they kind
of have to hook me on these days is like
am i going to commit
a ton of time to it or am i just going
to dip my feet in just to see
and uh while i definitely think it looks
good that's kind of my stance it's like
it does seem similar
to the other far crys of which i have
played many at this point in time
um i think i'd be interested to see a
little bit more
uh but otherwise you know it's
really consistently blown away by a lot
of those environments
it looked really pretty to me so
certainly impressed by that
and this man is the cutest man i've ever
seen
in my life so
we will take that